une précarité qui s'installe dans le
département et des signaux plutôt
inquiétants comme la présence plus
importante d'enfants dans les familles
c'est l'un des principaux indicateurs
aux relevés par les bénévoles du secours
catholique des yvelines les familles
avec au fond c 49 % des ménages
rencontrés pour cette année 2010 9 sas
est quelque chose qui est nouveau sur
les sur les cinq dernières années où
globalement la politique familiale quand
même permettait par la présence des
enfants d'avoir des compléments de
revenus pour les ménages
aujourd'hui ces aspects là sont plus du
tout suffisant et quand on a un quart
des ménages qu'on reçoit qui sont des
femmes avec enfants des femmes et des
mères isolées on va dire ça veut dire
pour nous les yvelines
on parle de 3000 sur ces cinq dernières
années le secours catholique d évident
note aussi une dégradation autour du
logement aujourd'hui et les
bénéficiaires ont pour la plus grande
majorité un logement précaire il n'y a
pas assez de construction de logement
social on reste coincé dans du logement
d'urgence ou du logement temporaire de
l'hébergement temporaire c'est pas de
logement du coup on reste dans une
situation précaire qui ne permet pas de
se projeter à long terme
autre donnée nouvelle pour l'année 2019
la proportion d'étrangers parmi les
personnes accueillies une proportion
stable pour la france mais qui devient
majoritaire pour la région francilienne
et les yvelines 69% des ménages
rencontrés sont de nationalité étrangère
s'ils viennent chez nous c'est qu'il ya
une dégradation de leur niveau
économique
un de leur situation et notamment pas de
droit à l'emploi
pas de droit au travail une
précarisation finalement qui se renforce
et du coup forcément y viennent ils
viennent de rentrer à noter que ce sont
les chiffres pour l'année 2019 avec la
crise sanitaire que connaît la france
depuis le mois de mars dernier
certaines associations tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé en millions de
français seraient passés sous le seuil
de pauvreté dans le courant de cette
année 2020 il rejoindrait les 9,3
millions de français déjà recensés dans
les yvelines secours catholique a
notamment était sollicité par des
étudiants et des retraités
et c'est un public plutôt nouveau